[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday March 21st I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Micron Technologies plans to invest 100
billion dollars to open a semiconductor
manufacturing campus in Clay New York
just outside Syracuse construction of
the plant is scheduled to start next
year and production will begin a few
years later
but there's already a problem a lack of
skilled workers in the area and that
could be a big challenge for the Biden
administration's ambitious plan to bring
chip manufacturing back to the U.S and
reduce the national and economic risks
of getting chips from Taiwan and other
countries with me now is wsj reporter
Joseph de Avila hi Joseph thanks for
joining me thank you
tell me a little bit about Clay New York
so clean New York is in this part of
Central New York it's a part of the
state where young people people who have
just graduated from college their
population is declining this is also an
area that historically has relied on
manufacturing jobs and when those jobs
started to leave in earlier decades
that's when we started to see some
challenges with the population and with
demographics
and the last time we saw the
employment Peak for the greater Syracuse
area was back in 2000 and that was
basically the high point for them and
they haven't matched that since and you
know since the pandemic all the jobs
that were lost during the pandemic
hasn't been fully recovered
Syracuse University is there and
obviously that's a huge draw for folks
and this is one of the major reasons why
Micron decided to even set up shop here
is because you know Syracuse is nearby
and there's a lot of other colleges that
couldn't provide a potential pipeline
for workers
okay so I guess that explains a little
bit why they picked this sort of classic
Rust Belt town for their big
semiconductor manufacturing plans what
kind of skills does it take to
manufacture these what kind of workers
will they need
so they're looking for engineers lots of
different engineers and so these are
folks that are going to have to have a
college degree in engineering and
there's going to be various types of
engineers that they're going to be
looking for and then the other part is
technicians so they're going to need
technicians to operate a lot of this
equipment and to help with maintenance
for the equipment and you know the the
company has been working with different
training centers trying to get out and
help with Workforce Development to build
that pipeline to add all these jobs over
the next few years
can you tell me a little bit more about
those programs so basically what Micron
is doing is they are working with local
universities and community colleges
they're working with them on beefing up
their curriculum they want to turn out
as many Engineers as possible they're
also investing in uh local training
programs to help folks who would like to
become a technician to work in the most
high-tech manufacturing that there is
and another thing that they're doing is
they are working with local K-12 schools
in the Syracuse region and they're
giving them some money for funding and
they really want these schools to be
building on their stem offerings to get
those young people interested in science
and math to help prepare them for
potential career at their new facilities
what do people who live in Clay New York
think of these programs
for a lot of folks there's an excitement
that this is going to be a big employer
that's coming they're going to be
offering good paying jobs average
salaries are going to be about a hundred
thousand dollars per year you know also
some folks who think it might be you
know too good to be true and they want
to see it before they believe it
that Micron was working with with the
state and local government on this you
know the chips and science act that was
signed into law last year included 39
billion dollars in incentives for
companies to start manufacturing chips
in the U.S is there any additional
funding to help Micron or other
companies build up its Workforce or
attract new workers
so yes they'll be applying for money
from the federal government through the
new Chips act and they have already
reached an agreement with New York state
to get 5.5 billion dollars in tax
benefits from the state and that's with
an agreement that they will create a 9
000 jobs over the next two decades is
in terms of finding Engineers for
High-Tech jobs like this it's definitely
something that's happening Nationwide
the association that represents the
companies that make semiconductors they
say that there's going to be a 20
increase in demand for engineers over
the next five years across the U.S so
it's definitely something that other
places are seeing as well the bind
Administration has really championed
domestic production of semiconductors
could the lack of workers derail that
well it'll certainly be a challenge and
that's one of the reasons why the Biden
Administration made this money available
this new pot of money is going to help
these companies build the facilities and
that's going to give them an extra
incentive to go out and make sure that
the workforce is trained and ready all
right that's our reporter Joseph de
Avila thanks for joining us Joseph thank
you
all right that's it for today's Tech
news briefing but a quick note before we
close the show we still want to hear
your questions about generative
artificial intelligence AI programs like
chat GPT Microsoft's new Bing or
mid-journing and we're going to answer
them on an upcoming episode leave us a
voicemail with your AI question at
415-439-6482 or send us an email with a
voice recording to tnb wsj.com we look
forward to hearing from you I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
thanks so much for listening
[Music]
thank you